Bem-vindo de volta à Computação Quântica na Prática. Este episódio vai se concentrar na primeira e muitas vezes na mais
desafiadora etapa na definição de um programa quântico: mapear um problema geral para um circuit que possa ser executado em um computador
quântico. Essa etapa descreve como um usuário, começando com um dado problema computacional,
pode traduzi-lo de modo que um computador quântico consiga entender.
Em lições anteriores desta série — lições dois e três — discutimos que a etapa de mapeamento é o primeiro passo de
quatro no framework Qiskit patterns. Nessas lições, você pode lembrar que nosso objetivo era traduzir
ou reescrever um problema computacional em uma função de custo ou um valor esperado
que pudemos avaliar usando um computador quântico.
Na lição três, discutimos um exemplo concreto com o Max Cut — um problema
computacionalmente difícil e bastante comum na otimização combinatória.
Naquele exemplo, passamos por várias etapas para transformar o grafo inicial em um problema nativo quântico. Transformamos
o problema de encontrar o número máximo de cortes no grafo em uma função de custo, depois reescrevemos essa função de custo
como um Hamiltoniano e preparamos um estado quântico de teste cujo estado fundamental
corresponde ao Max Cut. Por fim, construímos um quantum circuit representando o estado quântico de teste de
interesse e depois adicionamos os gates específicos para permitir que o estado evolua ao longo do tempo. Essa sequência de etapas é o que chamamos de
mapeamento. E em alto nível, o procedimento é geral para muitas outras aplicações, como química quântica
e simulação quântica. Agora, não tem como fugir do fato de que mapear pode ser difícil. Não há uma
estratégia única para cada problema, então pode ser intimidante. Hoje, vou destacar
alguns exemplos representativos de problemas diferentes e descrever como foram mapeados em cada caso. Vou resumir rapidamente
o que aprendemos sobre problemas de grafos como os usados no Max Cut e dedicar o restante da aula a como
mapear problemas que aparecem na natureza, como problemas de estrutura molecular em biologia, problemas de estrutura
eletrônica em química e simulação de teorias de campo quântico em física de altas energias.
Mas antes de passarmos a maior parte do tempo neste episódio analisando exemplos de problemas da literatura, quero te dar uma
visão geral das principais coisas que queremos realizar e considerar quando mapeamos um problema. Há
algumas coisas a considerar para qualquer tipo de problema computacional que precisará ser traduzido em um quantum circuit.
Primeiro, pode ser necessário simplificar o problema para torná-lo viável. Isso é algo comum à maioria das disciplinas científicas.
Não é exclusivo da computação quântica. Se você já ouviu a expressão "assuma uma
vaca esférica", ela alude ao fato de que muitas vezes é difícil descrever um sistema exatamente como ele aparece.
Mas podemos fazer simplificações razoáveis que ainda podem levar a soluções úteis.
Alguns exemplos de como poderíamos fazer isso na computação quântica são: limitar o tamanho ou a profundidade do circuit escolhendo um
ansatz eficiente em hardware, ou truncar evoluções temporais complexas, ou negligenciar
termos do Hamiltoniano que contribuem pouco para a energia final de um estado quântico.
O próximo ponto que quero fazer é que você vai ter que pensar em escrever o problema de uma forma que o computador quântico consiga entender.
Frequentemente, isso envolve fazer estas três perguntas. Um: o que os nossos qubits
vão representar neste modelo? Dois: o nosso problema é contínuo? Como os computadores quânticos são digitais, você precisará
encontrar uma forma de discretizar o problema. E três, por último: a topologia do problema se alinha com a topologia do
hardware? Se sim, ótimo. Mas se não, talvez precisemos implementar alguns truques para fazer funcionar. Então vamos abordar
essa primeira pergunta — o que acho que está no coração de todas as dificuldades em entender o mapeamento, especialmente como um
novo conceito. O que um qubit pode representar?
Os qubits podem ser usados para representar muitas coisas. A primeira e mais simples na minha opinião é um nó em um grafo. Os grafos são
usados para mostrar conectividade em muitos tipos diferentes de problemas matemáticos, e os nós são um elemento fundamental representando um ponto
ou entidade dentro de uma rede. Dependendo do que toda a rede representa, isso pode ser uma cidade, uma pessoa ou um
ferromagneto em uma rede. Os qubits também podem ser usados para representar bósons e férmions. Embora devo alertar aqui
que um único qubit não equivale exatamente a um bóson ou a um férmion. É um pouco
mais complicado que isso, e vou entrar nisso em breve, mas em geral, uma cadeia de spins que segue certas estatísticas é
algo que pode ser facilmente traduzido para uma arquitetura de qubits.
Agora, entramos em exemplos um pouco mais complicados. Para esses modelos, não faz mais sentido
falar em termos de um único qubit.
Em vez disso, precisamos de grupos deles para compor algo físico. Por exemplo, um
grupo de qubits aqui representado em uma topologia heavy-hexagonal pode ser usado para representar localizações geométricas de aminoácidos
ou cadeias de polímeros. Outro exemplo é a simulação de espalhamento de hádrons
em modelos de física de altas energias, que pode ser feita simulando a evolução temporal de um pacote de ondas hadrônico. Nesse caso,
um registrador de qubits pode ser usado para codificar diferentes estados de um campo quântico. O estado de vácuo desse campo ou
um pacote de ondas que se propaga sobre este vácuo.
Agora, quero também observar que mapear o problema para um computador quântico tem etapas distintas, que são: um, mapear os
estados em qubits e circuits; e dois, mapear a função de custo ou os valores esperados
dos observáveis e operadores quânticos. Veremos como esses são tratados em exemplos específicos. Mas
neste ponto já falamos de forma suficientemente abstrata sobre o desafio que temos diante de nós.
Vamos nos aprofundar nesses exemplos agora.
Vamos começar com nosso primeiro exemplo. Na minha opinião, um dos problemas de mapeamento mais fáceis é o que já
cobrimos com alguma profundidade: o exemplo do Max Cut. Naquele problema, o mapeamento foi bastante fácil para nós porque um qubit
equivalia a um nó no nosso grafo. Usar nós em um grafo é muito intuitivo e isso é
conveniente porque corresponde a muitas aplicações. Muitas vezes, quando você quer modelar algo que corresponde a uma
série de nós conectados entre si, se os agrupamentos são binários, como zero ou um, ou incluído ou não incluído em um
conjunto, você pode simplesmente e naturalmente mapear esses nós em bits ou qubits.
Neste exemplo, e até no que escalamos para 100 qubits no episódio 3, a conectividade do grafo
já correspondia à topologia do nosso hardware supercondutor. Então não precisamos nos preocupar com isso também. Claro que nem sempre é assim.
E se você tiver um grafo mais complicado ou conectado do que os exemplos que destacamos até agora, você vai precisar
implementar swap gates. Mas isso é tratado na segunda etapa dos Qiskit patterns, que se preocupa com
a transpilação. A outra parte do problema do Max Cut que o torna tão prático é que
já sabemos como expressar a função de custo como um Hamiltoniano usando a formulação QUBO.
Lembre que na computação quântica e nos algoritmos quânticos variacionais, uma função de custo Hamiltoniana é uma função
que codifica a solução ótima do problema no estado fundamental do Hamiltoniano.
Para construir o Hamiltoniano de custo, pudemos usar a classe sparse Pauli op no Qiskit para especificar a
conectividade do nosso grafo, e a etapa de mapeamento para os operadores quânticos está concluída. E o quantum circuit foi
simplesmente o ansatz QAOA. Agora, se isso não te soar familiar, por favor volte e confira o episódio 3, onde percorremos
isso com muito mais detalhe. Agora, vamos aumentar a dificuldade um pouquinho. A seguir, vamos analisar
um exemplo modelado no artigo chamado "Algoritmo quântico eficiente em recursos para dobramento de proteínas", escrito pela
IBM em colaboração com a Universidade de New South Wales. Um pouco de contexto de bioquímica. As proteínas são
macromoléculas compostas de longas cadeias de aminoácidos. Essas longas cadeias se dobram
em estruturas complexas que realizam uma grande variedade de funções biológicas.
Determinar a estrutura de uma proteína em um espaço tridimensional e entender as relações entre
estrutura e função estão entre os problemas mais desafiadores da bioquímica hoje.
As proteínas se dobram em estruturas úteis devido às interações entre os próprios aminoácidos.
À medida que a estrutura gira e se dobra, aminoácidos que estão distantes uns dos outros na cadeia podem acabar bem próximos
uns dos outros e interagir fortemente. Precisamos obter um Hamiltoniano descrevendo todas essas interações entre os aminoácidos
se queremos prever qual estrutura final vai minimizar a energia. Aqui vamos nos focar nas cadeias de aminoácidos e
em como elas podem ser modeladas em um computador quântico e, em seguida, como podemos obter distâncias entre aminoácidos para
cálculo das energias de interação.
Com isso, na verdade reuniremos todas as contribuições necessárias ao Hamiltoniano para simulá-lo
em um computador quântico. Em proteínas reais, os aminoácidos podem ocupar um continuum de localizações possíveis.
Porém, vamos usar uma simplificação aqui e restringi-los a um modelo de rede onde cada aminoácido
ocupa um ponto em uma grade. Aqui, os autores usaram uma rede tetraédrica.
Uma nota rápida: estamos codificando a direção das arestas, e não os nós em si, como no problema do Max Cut.
Cada qubit representa um possível caminho de etapa única ao longo da grade tetraédrica. Observe que os locais adjacentes foram
rotulados neste diagrama como A ou B por causa de suas diferentes orientações na rede.
A cadeia proteica é representada como uma série de curvas ou direções nesta
rede. Cada curva entre os aminoácidos pode estar em uma de quatro direções,
correspondendo às arestas do tetraedro.
Essas quatro possíveis curvas são codificadas usando quatro qubits.
Parece um pouco complicado. Vamos analisar esse exemplo com um pouco mais de profundidade.
Vamos colocar nosso primeiro aminoácido neste ponto na rede tetraédrica. A direção do primeiro
aminoácido para o segundo é arbitrária, porque o sistema sempre pode ser rotacionado para fazer essa aresta apontar
em qualquer direção que quisermos. Então vamos colocar nosso segundo aminoácido aqui. Não é tão fácil de
ver, mas o caminho do segundo para o terceiro também é na verdade arbitrário. Todas as três escolhas resultariam
em ter duas das arestas com um ângulo de aproximadamente 109,5°
entre elas. Escolher essa segunda aresta simplesmente determina a orientação da nossa proteína no espaço. Então, sem perda de
generalidade, podemos escolher as primeiras curvas como sendo apenas 0 0 1 e 0 0 1
0. Com essas simplificações, a configuração da cadeia de aminoácidos é simplesmente dada por essa expressão.
Até aqui mapeamos as arestas do tetraedro para qubits e nosso quantum circuit será um ansatz. Agora precisamos
considerar como codificar a energia do problema em um Hamiltoniano de modo que seu estado fundamental nos dê o padrão de
dobramento ótimo. Agora, para qualquer configuração dada haverá uma energia associada devido às
interações entre os próprios aminoácidos. Essas interações são mais fortes quando os dois aminoácidos estão
próximos entre si. Obviamente, aminoácidos que são adjacentes na espinha dorsal da cadeia sempre vão interagir entre
si. Mas como a proteína pode se torcer e dobrar, outros pares de aminoácidos
também podem interagir. Os aminoácidos 10 e 20, por exemplo, podem acabar em
locais adjacentes após a proteína ter se dobrado. Aminoácidos que acabam próximos um do outro têm interações
mais fortes e impulsionam o processo de dobramento, mas não necessariamente têm índices próximos entre
si. Então precisamos de uma fórmula para descrever a distância D entre os aminoácidos I e
J usando as informações codificadas nos qubits de configuração. Dessa forma, podemos
usar sua distância de separação para determinar quão fortemente eles estão interagindo. Isso é um pouco complicado,
mas tenha paciência, porque é um truque bacana. Primeiro, vamos introduzir uma função f sub a de i que indica se
ou não uma aresta a é usada para a curva no aminoácido i. Aqui, a pode assumir qualquer
das quatro direções possíveis. Em função da codificação de configuração acima, podemos escrever essas funções e então podemos
definir uma diferença no número de curvas rotuladas a nas redes A e B do
índice I ao índice J como delta N. Por que faríamos isso? Bem, resulta que a
rede tetraédrica tem uma propriedade muito útil. Vamos focar neste aminoácido aqui. Não importa qual é,
mas vamos chamá-lo de aminoácido E. Queremos saber quão distante estará o aminoácido j. E tudo o que temos
são as arestas ao longo das quais a espinha dorsal avança. Partindo de I, note que um passo
para fora do centro ao longo de um tipo específico de aresta — chame-a de a, a partir deste ponto da rede A —
é exatamente oposto e é desfeito por um passo para fora ao longo da aresta a a partir dos
pontos b. Portanto, vários passos ao longo da aresta A a partir de qualquer ponto da rede A afastam a
espinha dorsal do aminoácido E, e passos ao longo do tipo de aresta A a partir dos pontos B
te trazem de volta. Então a distância entre dois aminoácidos I e J ao longo do tipo de
aresta que vamos rotular A depende da diferença entre os passos feitos ao longo das arestas A
a partir dos pontos A e dos pontos B. Como A e B alternam necessariamente na
espinha dorsal proteica, isso é capturado pelo termo (-1) elevado a K. E esse argumento se aplica a outros tipos de aresta também.
Portanto, a distância entre aminoácidos nas etapas da rede tetraédrica pode ser calculada no final por esta
expressão. Mas como obtemos o Hamiltoniano a partir desta longa equação para a distância total entre os aminoácidos? Há
na verdade uma correspondência um-para-um entre essas distâncias nas etapas da rede tetraédrica e a
distância euclidiana. E você pode ver que já calculei algumas das expressões.
Essas distâncias podem ser usadas no cálculo da energia da sua configuração.
Dependendo do seu propósito, você pode ditar uma distância de corte abaixo da qual considera o par como interagindo,
ou pode fazer algo mais complicado. Pode não ser óbvio, mas na verdade já terminamos com a etapa de
mapeamento ao fazer isso. Os estados dos qubits indicam a curva, e a coleção de curvas dita a
distância entre qualquer par de aminoácidos. Pares de várias espécies de aminoácidos
têm interações diferentes, algumas atrativas, outras repulsivas. Se você estiver usando a configuração e distância apenas para
determinar se as interações de aminoácidos conhecidos estão ativas ou inativas,
as intensidades dessas são bem conhecidas. Não por mim, mas você pode consultá-las em uma tabela como esta. Então, em resumo,
neste exemplo, os qubits são usados para marcar localizações em uma rede que juntos formam uma cadeia de aminoácidos.
E simulando como elas se dobram e se curvam, esperamos encontrar melhores resultados na pesquisa médica. Agora,
pulamos como calcular alguns termos deste Hamiltoniano porque eram muito específicos para este problema. Embora definir
direções em uma rede possa ser aplicado de forma mais geral.
Agora que você tem um Hamiltoniano geral, sempre vai querer traduzi-lo para operadores de Pauli, que
são nativos ao computador quântico. É isso que discutiremos a seguir.
Vamos continuar. Agora vamos explorar como traduzir um sistema de partículas subatômicas em operadores de Pauli. As partículas subatômicas
são divididas em duas categorias: bósons e férmions. Os bósons
como fótons ou o bóson de Higgs obedecem a um certo conjunto de regras estatísticas, e os férmions como elétrons ou neutrinos obedecem a outro.
A principal diferença entre eles é que os bósons podem ocupar o mesmo estado. Não há limite para quantos
bósons podem estar no estado fundamental ou em qualquer outro estado excitado. Os férmions, por outro lado, são egoístas. Eles exigem que
cada partícula tenha seu próprio estado quântico. Os bósons também têm spins inteiros, enquanto os férmions têm spins semi-inteiros,
como o spin 1/2 do elétron ou partículas de spin três meios mais exóticas.
Para descrever um sistema de partículas, precisamos de uma descrição de sua energia. Vamos focar nos férmions. Podemos começar com o
Hamiltoniano escrito em termos do que chamamos de operadores C. Esses são basicamente objetos matemáticos que
correspondem a criar ou aniquilar um férmion de um estado no sistema.
Estes são frequentemente escritos como fi dagger e fi em uma notação que chamamos de segunda
quantização. Agora, fi dagger é o operador que cria um férmion no estado i. Fi é
o operador que destrói um férmion no estado i. Mas lembre que os computadores quânticos geralmente operam em uma
base de qubits com regras específicas para representar sistemas fermiônicos. Eles não trabalham inerentemente na linguagem dos
operadores fermiônicos. Para preencher essa lacuna, precisamos mapear a notação de segunda quantização para operadores de Pauli, que
correspondem naturalmente a quantum gates.
Há várias transformações dessas para férmions. Uma escolha comum é a transformação de Jordan-Wigner.
Os mapeamentos de Bravyi-Kitaev e de paridade são mais recentes para codificações fermiônicas.
As operações bosônicas, por outro lado, podem ser transformadas usando a transformação de Holstein-Primakoff ou mapeando diretamente
os estados de Fock para uma sub-base dos modos bosônicos disponíveis.
E há outras opções para bósons também. Outras codificações também estão sendo ativamente pesquisadas. Mas por enquanto,
vamos focar apenas na transformação de Jordan-Wigner.
Então por que não simplesmente atribuir um qubit para representar cada elétron? Bem, não podemos.
Os qubits são distinguíveis e os elétrons não. Por exemplo, podemos facilmente rotular e identificar qubits individuais em
qualquer dispositivo, mas a indistinguibilidade dos elétrons significa que não podemos rotulá-los de forma alguma. Precisamos na verdade rotular
os operadores de acordo com os orbitais ocupados, como 1s, 2s e 2p,
em vez de elétrons específicos. Portanto, precisamos rotular os operadores de acordo com os orbitais ocupados como 1s,
2s e 2p, em vez de rotular elétrons específicos. Então cada qubit desempenha
aproximadamente o papel de um orbital na molécula, que está ocupado ou desocupado.
Mas como fazemos isso é na verdade um pouco mais complicado. Então agora introduzimos algo chamado de mapeamento de Jordan-Wigner para acompanhar a
anti-simetria e garantir que a estatística correta do sistema fermiônico geral está sendo obedecida. O mapeamento de
Jordan-Wigner é conceitualmente simples por causa da correspondência um-para-um entre os orbitais e os qubits. Há
outros mapeamentos que alcançam um objetivo semelhante, incluindo o mapeamento de paridade.
O cálculo da paridade de um estado requer considerar múltiplos qubits. No mapeamento de paridade e em outros, a
interpretação de um qubit correspondendo a um orbital não se aplica.
Agora vamos passar por um exemplo bem simples juntos para garantir que entendemos essa transformação.
Digamos que queremos calcular a interação de single qubit f dagger f. Começamos inserindo nossas definições para os
operadores de levantamento e abaixamento. Então podemos agrupar termos fatorando a matriz identidade i e o 1/4.
Como vemos, ficamos com termos que serão familiares para quem lida com relações de comutação. Este termo aqui
entre parênteses é nada menos que i vezes o comutador de x zero e y. E não
esqueça a identidade que tiramos.
Lembre que são apenas matrizes de Pauli. Portanto, o comutador é bem conhecido. O comutador de x e y nessa
ordem é simples: é 2iz. Certifique-se de não perder o controle dos seus sinais negativos e você chegará a este resultado final.
No final, reescrevemos com sucesso uma expressão fermiônica em
termos de operadores de Pauli que nosso computador quântico conseguirá entender.
Vamos discutir rapidamente como implementaríamos o mapeamento de Jordan-Wigner no Qiskit, porque embora eu ache
importante entender como o mapeamento e transformações semelhantes funcionam e ver trabalhado pelo menos uma vez, você
não vai querer ter que fazer toda essa conta manualmente toda vez.
Especialmente para sistemas de grande porte, podemos fazer uso da função sparse Pauli op no Qiskit para
facilmente criar as operações de Pauli associadas a partir de um mapeamento. Uma implementação não-ótima
vai usar loops aninhados e leva cerca de 20 linhas de código.
Vou linkar o código aqui para todos explorarem. Mas em alto nível, os passos são os seguintes.
Um: usar a função sparse Pauli ops from list para criar um operador identidade
correspondente ao tamanho do espaço de parâmetros a ser mapeado. Dois: seguindo a definição dos operadores de criação
e aniquilação mostrados anteriormente, usar a função sparse Pauli ops from list para definir operações de Pauli de x, y e z.
Isso vai mapear os operadores de criação e aniquilação fermiônicos para operadores de spin de qubits, codificando o número de ocupação fermiônico
na base computacional dos qubits. E três: gerar o Hamiltoniano desejado
na base de Pauli aplicando os operadores acima nos orbitais de interesse. Isso geralmente corresponde à
criação de uma matriz identidade representando o núcleo — os orbitais não interagentes — e depois aplicando os operadores de criação
e aniquilação ao espaço ativo com pesos que correspondem às especificidades do problema em questão.
Como mencionei, esta é apenas uma decomposição de alto nível. O código não é tão complicado, e você deve agora
se sentir confiante em adaptá-lo a outros problemas de interesse.
Agora que entendemos completamente o esquema de mapeamento de Jordan-Wigner, vamos vê-lo em ação em uma configuração mais complicada. Você
talvez lembre deste artigo de um episódio anterior também, sobre dinâmica de hádrons. Não vou passar pelo artigo novamente em profundidade, mas por favor confira
o episódio anterior se você perdeu e está curioso. Neste exemplo, o mapeamento de Jordan-Wigner é usado para
expressar o Hamiltoniano de sítios em uma rede com L sítios para o modelo de Schwinger na ausência de um campo elétrico. Aqui,
é muito mais difícil identificar precisamente o que um qubit representa neste modelo, porque é apenas a
coleção de qubits juntos que compõe algo físico. Neste contexto, um pacote de ondas. Em vez disso, você pode
pensar aproximadamente nos qubits como pedaços discretizados de espaço, onde aqui L é o volume da rede em que cada elemento ou
célula unitária compreende dois qubits. Os operadores fermiônicos que vimos no slide anterior descrevem a amplitude da
função de onda em um sítio específico.
Então nosso Hamiltoniano contém esses operadores fermiônicos de levantamento e abaixamento. Mas para implementar tal
Hamiltoniano em um computador quântico, precisaremos expressá-lo em termos de operadores de spin, não os operadores fermiônicos.
Então usamos a transformação de Jordan-Wigner. Após aplicar a transformação de Jordan-Wigner, nosso novo
Hamiltoniano se torna esta equação na parte inferior do slide, onde sigma plus é o operador de Pauli X + iY e sigma
minus é X - iY. Uma vez que temos um Hamiltoniano escrito neste formato, a
parte difícil da etapa de mapeamento acabou e agora pode ser facilmente escrito em um circuit em operadores de Pauli.
Em resumo, discutimos quatro exemplos de como técnicas específicas de mapeamento têm sido usadas recentemente no
campo da computação quântica. Começando pelo mais simples e indo até a aplicação da transformação de Jordan-Wigner à
dinâmica de hádrons. Percebo que é muita coisa. Este material foi muito técnico,
e se você não o viu antes, pode ser muito intimidante. A boa notícia é que eu prometo que fica mais fácil e
mais familiar quanto mais tempo você passa praticando. E esse é o nome do jogo, e é por isso que nomeei toda a
série Computação Quântica na Prática.
Não é algo que alguém pode simplesmente pegar e ir com desde o começo. Requer algum estudo, alguma
coceira de cabeça e provavelmente alguns momentos de frustração. Mas encorajo a todos a ficarem com o desconforto e
realmente explorarem as dúvidas que surgem à medida que continuam, porque é a única forma de realmente aprender. Obrigada por
assistir. Este foi o episódio 5 da Computação Quântica na Prática. Na próxima vez vamos explorar como simular
um Hamiltoniano do zero. Até em breve.